and we've had all sorts of landmark
moments when it comes to this disease
but perhaps this
might well be among the most depressing
this shows you the number of people
who've
died cumulative total of people who have
died across the world from covert 19
look at it climbing over the course of
the last few months well
where is it now it is around the million
mark so one million people
have died of this disease around the
world and if we break down where those
deaths have happened
well it's probably a relatively familiar
story so around a quarter of them just
under a quarter
in europe uh there you have asia of
course the disease
uh came out of china but now in india
you're seeing a lot of deaths
uh more recently and then the americas
well
more than half of these deaths happening
uh in north america or obviously united
states
and in brazil as well big outbreak in
brazil
too now how high is it going to get well
the who thinks it might well get up to
two million deaths before there's a
vaccine so kind of doubling this
total and obviously we're now
potentially in this second wave at the
moment
but how does this compare historically
it's worth just kind of bearing that in
mind it's a big number but
what about the comparison with other
pandemics we've seen in the past well
let me just kind of show you that so
i've put covert 19 over here that's a
million but you can imagine that being a
little bit taller
if we're getting up to that two million
the who is talking about
a typical flu season more or less four
hundred thousand obviously it varies
depending
on the year so russian flu kind of
significant outbreak there was was more
about 700 000 but
we're already above that level uh with
covert 19
so far hong kong flew over there that
was in the 60s we're talking about one
to four million so kind of around
maybe around the mark that covered 90
might get to if the who
is right asian flu similar as well but
bear in mind in neither of those two
outbreaks or indeed any of the outbreaks
other than covert 19 did we see the kind
of lockdowns that we've seen globally so
very different picture there and of
course
really this is the the mother of all
pandemics the spanish
influenza 1918 to 1920
no one really knows for sure how many
deaths except that it was an
extraordinary number 17 million perhaps
50 million maybe some people think a
hundred
million so a massive difference with
covert 19 but as i say it was a
different world
and a different situation in terms of
lockdowns now
as i say we are facing uh potentially a
second wave of disease in the uk it's
worth just updating you on where we are
on that because probably you'll
recall what we heard uh this time last
week so that there is
cases there's cases not deaths of
disease you can see they've been
gradually going higher but of course
sir patrick vanessa chief scientific
advisors the government talked about
this curve this was the kind of scary
shot the scary number that we saw
last week from him if it doubled every
seven days he said that's what you're
heading for about 50 000 cases
by the middle of october and it's worth
just doing a check
we've had a week's worth of extra data
so it's worth just asking where are we
now what's the outcome well you can see
it up only
relatively gradually over the course of
the last week and a bit
doubling every 10 to 12 days and you can
see the difference between doubling
every 10 or 12 days
is very different to doubling every
seven days exponential growth it's one
of those scary things
but this is not quite as scary as that
chart that we saw
last week and um some people have asked
whether it's just the cases numbers and
they can't be relied on and maybe the
picture in hospitals is worse than what
we're getting from cases because you
know do we know about the testing
figures well
i can show you hospitalizations okay so
hospitalizations from covert 19
in england annoyingly the scottish
numbers aren't very reliable at the
moment but this is hospital admissions
for cover 19.
you can see they are going up this is
just the last few weeks since
uh august but it's still again it's
doubling every 10
days or so it's not the rates that sir
patrick vanessa was talking about but
you know this should make no one
comfortable now
before you say anything yes this is just
the last
few months last few weeks really and it
does look quite scary
but let's zoom out for a moment because
it's a very different picture if we zoom
out and look at emissions same same data
same data but going back
uh to march and you can see a big
difference between that peak there
and this section here which is what we
were just showing that's the section
here perhaps you've seen that chart of
hospitalizations rising well
it's very small isn't it in comparison
uh with what happened
back in the spring but this is really
the key question
and you know there is no definitive
answer on that are we just facing a kind
of gradual uptick at the moment that's
going to continue to be gradual
or is this just the early stage
of where the data didn't even exist last
time around in other words are we
going to are we going to start to
rise up and see hospitalizations get up
to that kind of level we saw last time
around
we don't really know and this is the
problem you know no one really knew
about the disease
back in february at least no one was
measuring very well what was happening
in the uk
and so either things are better than
last time around or we just haven't got
the measurements yet i'm
afraid there is no definitive note on it
except to say
it isn't rising at quite the rate that
uh separate valence talked about and
there's a bit of good news there
it is worth saying as well we're getting
a bit more data a bit more information
about possibly where this disease might
have come from
you know the ins does a survey of of who
has the disease perhaps the most
reliable one
they've broken it down by who has been
traveling uh who's basically done a
staycation stayed in the uk
or who's traveled abroad so the higher
these lines are the the higher the
incidence of the disease so that's
people who stayed at home didn't travel
and let's have a look at people who did
travel look it's gone up a lot more
sharply so
there's a thesis that this second wave
of disease was imported from
france from spain this time around
people were supposed to be quarantining
did they did the disease just come
anyway
this would seem to underline that and
actually when you look at what's
happened in france and in spain
well the disease is indeed spreading in
those countries and it's at a slightly
earlier stage than the uk
so what i've got here is i've got the
trajectories of where they are so right
now
france is around there spain rising
rising rising
and they right now are around there
according to the latest data
whereas the uk so it's over here
following more or less the same path you
can see that's where we are now
but going in line with where france and
spain have been going over the course of
the last
few weeks and there's good news and
there's bad news about that
the good news is that this path is not
as steep nowhere near as steep as the
one that subatomic violence laid out
that scary line going up i talked about
a moment ago it's not as steep as that
and the other good news is that
the spanish cases actually start to tail
off
a bit in the most recent weeks so more
or less flattening out just above 10
000 cases whether we can rely on the
numbers or whether that's going to
change we'll have to see
but it's not quite as scary as last time
around but of course the bad news is
that when you see cases go up deaths
also follow this is
still a very dangerous disease even
though we are getting a bit better at
treating it
and so we are seeing death starting to
rise ever so gradually
in spain and in france as well as
hospitalizations
as well so any increase is not something
anyone should be comfortable about
but i would say this as well this is
this is showing you same thing again but
for deaths in
france and in spain you can see they are
gradually going up and in the uk um you
know you can barely really see any
increase at all
but just compare it again with what we
saw last time around the profile for
deaths
from covert 19 back in march was
very very different indeed so it all
comes back to that big question
do you think it's just too early to say
for sure that we're not going to go on
that path
or is the data already bearing out that
we are bringing this disease more
under control it's still an open
question but so far the news is
quietly encouraging but watch the space